inside this van were two fathers two
mothers and fortune
they had hope they would escape this
latest bombardment but it followed them
a single rocket killed everyone inside
most of the images are too awful to show
young children and their parents wrap
together here in blankets
it is volunteer rescue workers who must
gather the dead as they've been doing
for so many years goodness knows what
the toll is for them
like over half a million others the
families in the red van had been fleeing
but in this final onslaught of the
decade-long war there is literally
nowhere to go on the roads out of both
the cities of Aleppo and Idlib convoys
of families push forward but the border
with Turkey ahead is closed
the Syrian government army is closing in
from behind and their Russian allies are
in the sky this is the town of kafir
umma just outside Lib city these are the
last pockets of land that President
Assad's army has not yet retaken and as
they push forward at any cost it seems
the UN is warning of death and
displacement at a level not yet seen in
this horrific to the south of Italy bin
Saraqeb Abu Ahmed his wife and three
sons and two daughters are preparing to
leave in the skies above the sounds of
the Russian and Syrian jets
[Music]
and Syrian helicopters with their barrel
bombs look again and you can see the
barrel bomb falling unguided
indiscriminate illegal in international
law but in this long war they continue
to be a central part of President
Assad's arsenal this is the hospital in
the town of area south of it Lib it is a
place where so many already injured
should be receiving treatment and it's
destroyed
in the countryside between aleppo and
idlib our cameraman found 12 year-old
mohammad al hollaby he was digging for
anything left in the rubble of his home
where his three siblings died it's hard
to believe this war could get worse but
in these final days it is mark stone sky
news